Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday flap ea April
17th, 2017 what's going on? How are,
yeah, happy Patriot's day, everybody.
Um, I believe that only woo.
It's one of my voice right now.
I believe that um,
Massachusetts is kind of the only place
that takes Patriot's day off kind of,
sort of, you know, they have
the Boston Marathon, right?
They usually play a red sox game during
the day for everybody doesn't want to
fucking run around and watch a bunch
of skinny people running down the damn
street,
shitting themselves on heartbreak hill
every year somebody shit's themselves in
that race.
You know that anytime there's a marathon,
there's people that push themselves so
hard that they literally shit themselves.
Okay.
It's a fucking running up the hill.
You know those runners,
they were those little fucking
nylon shorts and stuff,
so there's nowhere for it to go.
And these maniacs,
they just stayed just keep running with
shit going down the back of their legs.
Like one of those fucking
horses that carried, you know,
drags the newlyweds around the park.
You know, but even then, you know,
they put the tail up,
they fucking shoot it out.
Always going in early with the shit jokes.
Everybody says what it's going to be.
Is it literally going to
be who should show? Um,
yeah.
Yeah, so whatever happy
Patriot's day to everybody.
I don't even know what Patriot's day is.
You know,
I don't think it's about the football
team because it's not football season
system. When we raised the banner
Patriot's Day, let's look it up. Shall We?
People Patriot's Day a Hashtag.
What the fuck is it?
Why does it automatically
go to fucking Wikipedia?
Even though I would have gone here.
All right. Then as I a Patriot Day,
a film starring Marky Mark Wahlberg.
That's not what I was looking for.
Fucking cock suckers. I just don't
understand. I had, oh my God,
I had the worst day with my fucking phone.
Like yesterday.
I tried to update it.
MMM.
You know,
and then it comes back on and then you
need all your fucking passwords and no
matter how much I type them in,
the way that it's supposed to be,
it doesn't recognize it.
Then it shuts down my phone.
Then it's going old la bones [inaudible]
guten tag and like 50 different fucking
languages. And I can't, I
can't. I came. So if I had not,
I haven't meditated in a month.
I'm not gonna lie to you, but I, I,
if I hadn't meditated so much,
the beginning part of the year,
I would have broke my phone
and half I grabbed it,
I turned it sideways and I fucking
started. I started to do it.
I started to fucking
break it and I stopped.
I did throw it at the
couch into the cushions.
And I also did throw my laptop into the,
they were all into the cushions,
not overly or, you know, it's
funny, when I lifted up the laptop,
I felt the pain of my rotator cuff
so I could only throw it so hard.
It was really pathetic. It was
a pathetic display of anger. Uh,
so, you know, I dunno my phone
still fucking with me. You don't,
I'm trying to go into the Goddamn apple
store here and they won't let me do it.
I don't understand these,
you know, apple is,
is everybody fucking loves
his con got company, you know.
Can somebody please fucking explain to
me why they're so hostile when it comes
to any sort of customer support.
Is there a fucking reason?
There's not a phone number. I can't
talk to anybody. They're like fuck you.
Here's our product that
doesn't work. Go Fuck Yourself.
We're not responsible for anything.
You don't know what we look like.
You don't know where we are.
Don't even talk to me about those fucking
apple stores with the people walking
around with a genius tee shirts.
Give me a fucking break. Oh,
that sounds says cause somebody just
came into my house and I hear it all the
time. So I mean it doesn't
mean shit to me anyways.
What, what, what? That was
like an anger meter. You know,
as I was getting up higher would ring and
it would let me know to come back down
again.
You know,
like an idiot light on some cars that
your engine's overheating anyways.
Fuck those apple stores too.
All right, those are dead, dead.
It's all bullshit.
You're talking to low level people in the,
in the company. Nobody who's fucking
designing these God damn things.
It ended up being fucked up.
It's working at that store.
Okay,
give that stupid fucking shirt. This
is genius. It shouldn't say pee on.
Um,
and then what do they got to deal with?
Fucking balding hot heads like me who
come walking in and going like to where
the fuck did all my music go?
Who did you put it on the cloud?
I don't want you to have my stuff.
Fine. I don't, you know, I should
have never stopped getting cds.
All I know is everything's fucked up.
Okay.
And so now I'm signing into shit on my
laptop. My phone's talking to me going,
hey,
somebody signing in on another device
and that there's no place for me to say,
yeah, I know it's me. And then the laptop
soon, the same thing. They're like,
it's like David Lee Roth and Eddie
van Halen. It's like, you guys,
you were great together.
We had the band and now you're fucking
break it up and you're talking shit about
each other and don't even talk to me about
those fucking numbers I'm supposed to
punch in because I did that too.
I went into my settings,
I fucking stupid. Uh, whatever.
Clicked on my name,
went into passwords type the fucking
number that they just sent me into the
thing and they said they didn't
recognize it and then they freeze up.
My phone frees up my phone, like I'm
working in the Pentagon or something.
Come some fucking general.
I'm just some jerk off once,
listen to some fucking hair metal from
the 80s get killed. Well, you know,
well I get on a treadmill.
It's all I'm trying to do here.
Okay.
You know what it is. It's
fucking, it's incestuous.
Yeah.
You know how really rich people want to
keep the money in their family, you know,
so they just sort of, they sort of
breed with the same five families.
I've taught you this before. So
it's why, you know, you look at the,
it's like they're,
they're good looking from the forehead
down to like the mouth area and then they
smile and it's Whoa,
you know,
starts looking like they should
be playing a fucking Banjo,
you know? So it's the same thing
with technology. Technology.
It used to be a radio was radio over
there? My Stereo dead over there.
It's the dishwasher right
slash made. I'm sorry,
I was just thinking about
the time I was talking about.
And then you had your walk wins,
right?
Then the walk when also had a fucking
radio and a phone was a phone and now
they've all four. They've all
just been gang bang, right?
This big fucking calendula.
Fucking fisting technological,
I dunno what they're all
the same goddamn thing now.
Everything, everything is just on
those fucking things. And I don't know,
it's ridiculous. So what I ended up
doing as I, after I started to like,
it was weird.
Like I had the strength signals sent
from all the way to like my wrist.
I didn't let it get to my hands. I felt
the anger go all like, it's like the hulk,
right? The fucking my arms turned green
all the way down to my wrist and I just,
I stopped myself from breaking it
in half, but I have to, Oh God,
that would have been such a great feeling
to just snap the has to be youtube
videos of people snapping their
fucking phones and half. Um,
what I did was I just said,
fuck that phone,
fuck the laptop and I had a drum lesson
and I got in my truck and I just fucking
drove over and yet can admit,
you know what,
it was kind of fucking nice
not having a phone, you know,
I wasn't looking at text
messages and dwell driving.
I wasn't doing any of that type of shit.
Trying to fucking scrolled in the
next God damn song, none of that shit.
I just was, I dunno, driving a car,
like I used to talking to myself and um,
then it came back calm down.
I tried it again and about, I don't
know, maybe the 17th attempt to,
I got it to work again and uh,
I just got it as you know,
is greatest.
These are and my ability to communicate
with you guys and everything like that.
You know, I still would been
our right without these things.
I could have made it the old fashioned
way as a comedian where he just keep
doing the clubs and doing the clubs.
Then I do a guest spot on the Hollywood
squares right next to Paul Lynde.
You know, maybe do a fucking tonight
show and I just keep building up.
I could have made it that way.
I didn't need all of this shit.
All this shit that these
fucking Yolo dishes, you know,
selfies and then the, the picture you
take that it takes sort of a video,
but it's a picture,
but it's also a video.
Okay.
You know, these flying squirrel
suits, I mean, I dunno.
Okay.
What is it you just to do shit that other
people didn't do? Is that what
it is? I don't fucking know.
You know, back in the day, you
know what it was back in the day,
you fucking did the clubs until you built
up enough of a following on your own
that you headlined clubs and then
maybe you got an hour special.
Then you know now if you're a middle act,
you need an hour special to headlines.
Like the whole thing is too.
I just feel like this old man,
like
what's the deal? All right.
Patriot's day, everybody.
Um,
Patriot's day.
Okay.
Whereas Patriot's day in Massachusetts,
in Wisconsin and Patriots Day in
Maine is an official state holiday
commemorating the anniversary of the
battles of Lexington and Concord.
Well, what the fuck does Maine and
Wisconsin have to do with that?
The first battles of the
American revolution or does,
does his main and Wisconsin,
the only other two fucking
states of respect to holiday.
The holiday was originally
celebrated on April 19th.
The actual anniversary of the battles
fought in 1775 since 1969 it has been
observed on the third Monday in April
in Massachusetts and in Maine. Doe.
Let's get a three day
weekend, Donovan, you know,
fuck the 19th just make
sure it's on a Monday.
It's also the first day of a vacation
week for public schools in both states in
both states and a school holiday for
many low local colleges and universities,
both public and private.
The day is a public school
observance stay in Wisconsin.
Florida law also encourages people to
celebrate it like those fucking people
needed an encouragement to
celebrate anything else.
If I could celebrate like
everyday's Patriot's day,
fucking meth day, though it is
not treated as a public holiday.
Okay.
Of observances in reenactments
of battles occur occur.
I remember going to one
of those when I was a kid.
I thought those people were cool as shit,
shooting the guns and pretending
to die and all that stuff.
I thought it was awesome. Then I got older
and I was like, Hey, what do you mean?
If that's what he's into? All
right. The Boston Marathon,
he's run on Patriot's day
every fucking year. Therefore,
sometimes the holiday is
referred to as marathon.
Monday at the Boston Red
Sox had been scheduled.
It had been scheduled to play at
home in Fenway park on Patriot's day.
Every year since 1959 the
games are postponed due to
weather and (596) 016-0560
seven and [inaudible] 84 do I need all
of this? All right, we got it. Okay.
We got it.
So that's what it is.
It's commemorating the first battles of
the American revolutions in Lexington
and Concord. I thought Gettysburg was
the first one. That wasn't the first one.
Oh, that was a civil war.
Oh my God. Shaking my head.
Shut up your fucking Wikipedia read and
can't nobody gives a fuck about your war
knowledge. Did you fight in it? Well then
shut up. All right. You know, it's funny,
before I came in here, right, I
was watching the Celtics lose.
It's a fresh loss at the time.
I'm, I'm taping this Sunday night,
a Celtics loss to a,
a giant Jamie Foxx and
the Chicago Bulls do that.
Butler guy looks like Jamie Foxx.
Circur like somewhere in the
90s in living color and uh,
you know, fucking brutal game,
brutal game, brutal game.
But it was also, you know,
with Isaiah losing his sister and
stuff, it was Kinda like, uh, the,
the drama of the game was definitely
just looked at us. It's a fucking game.
Look what this guy's going through,
but the balls as much as they're
an eighth seat, you know,
let's go a little sports morning,
talk radio all day.
You don't leave Chicago Bulls,
these bunches here or an AC.
Do you have a lot of veteran
presence? Ed? Can you experience? Oh,
would you Dwayne way
will you ever ride go and
yeah, it's not going to be an easy one.
Um, and then they got that Unabomber guy.
Like, I dunno what the fuck that
guy's deal is. You know what I mean?
I think when I look at that guy,
his do the hair do he has
and the fucking facial hair.
Okay.
I just hear his agent, you
know, going like, dude,
we've tried everything to get you
a lucrative advertising contracts.
We got nothing. So, you know,
why don't you just be the crazy
fucking heroin bearded face guy.
Why don't we try that? Did the
bird man retire yet? You know,
I used to get claustrophobic looking
at that guy's fucking tattoos.
They just kept going higher and higher.
Like the little he would choke in them.
Um, very colorful, very marvel comic.
Um, yeah. So we lost whatever Bam. Fucking
one game. You know, what are you gonna do?
I mean, we live and die, but we got
one guy, we got fucking Isaiah Thomas.
That's our guy. Okay? He's the fucking
guy. We live and die by the threes.
We don't get fucking offensive boards
and I'll die and get away with that in
the regular season. Maco playoff time.
You don't,
you won't get it.
Oh,
that's what I'm worried about.
And the Bruins blow it.
You blew it. We fucking
blue game. We blew it.
We fucking blew it a game too. I think
we forgot that there was a third period.
We were all impressed with ourselves.
You know,
we scored three goals in the second
period of something like that or to
something. We were up three. Here
we have three to one, three to one.
Everything's going good.
And the cross checking cons that are,
the auto was centered as Jesus Christ.
If one auto was centered, a fed bitched
about the refereeing in that game,
I saw one play like this fucking guy,
he crosschecked the same guy twice,
right in front of the net.
The guy went down twice call.
It was like every fucking third
crosscheck that, uh, they would call.
And then that,
that color commentator was so pro auto.
It was fucking ridiculous that that first
one that was trying to say that, that,
you know, the goal was offsides.
It's like kind of, can you tell that?
He definitely seems like he moves his leg,
but there's no way you can see
from that shitty angle from nine.
I love the NHL too.
It's like they're going to,
they're going to implement fucking replay,
but then for whatever reason they're
going to have a camera on top of the God
damn arena. At least that's
the feed we got. It's like,
how the fuck can you tell what the
guys on site or not? I don't know.
It might've been a good call.
Might have been a bad call.
I had no idea what the color
common day was, was convinced.
That's a doubt that they should,
that they should have call that went back.
Oh fuck you just go skate down the
Goddamn river and go get your fucking
whatever. Whatever the fuck you guys
eat up there. Um, so what it was,
we'll see how that one goes.
Um,
okay.
I'm hoping I bows basically open the same
thing for the Bruins and the Celtics.
I know we're not winning the
championship and either fucking league.
I'm just hoping we can go
as far as we can. All right.
Get some good playoff
experience and build on that.
That's what the fuck I'm looking for.
That's it. That's all. Nothing crazy.
You know I didn't even look to see if a,
I know the predators.
They won that first game. One
to nothing. A pitcher's duel.
See, wow. See what the fuck
happened with them and game too.
I know the fucking ranges and the
fucking Canadians are playing.
What do we got here? What's going
on? What's going on in the world?
The NHL fucking penguins.
They're the team to beat man.
Fuck the capitals till the
capital's do something.
Okay.
Ah, the fucking Canadians want again.
God, I hate those fucking pastors.
They're not going to win shit though.
Blue is take a three game to
none series over the wild.
What else do we got here? What's
going on with the phone? Come on my,
can you just give me the fucking scores
here? Oh, Pittsburgh wins in overtime.
All right, well where's the rest of
the, where's the rest of the scores?
What happened yesterday?
Chicago when
she,
should it be this difficult?
Should you just go on the website and
it's just all right there for mouth
breathing morons like me? Is this
asking too much? I went the wrong way.
Nashville one five to nothing.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Anaheim's up two games to not
Nashville's up two games to none.
Toronto beat Washington and
overtime. Ah, and I wonder,
I didn't hear from fucking Josh,
Adam Meyers.
Okay.
We lost in overtime. All
right, let's fuck this page.
I don't want to go back
and relive this shit.
So, um, yeah, that's what I did today.
That's what I've been doing this weekend.
Hanging out with my daughter and
I'm just watching the playoffs.
I watched that fucking f one race and
by rain whenever the hell that one was
that I actually taped it this time.
I had a great time watching it.
And the Ferrari's when again,
when again,
what's his face one it and I
didn't write down his name.
One of those v guys want it.
You know,
Hamilton got fucking penalize
five seconds for driving too slow,
slowing up Ricardo. And then people
would go and like, Hey, you know what?
I don't think he should have been a,
I don't think he should have been
penalized for uh, for fucking,
basically what was happening was Mercedes
was pitting both their cars at the
same fucking time, you know,
so the other guys in there,
the guy was not Nico Rosberg,
he's in there, that bolt to Skye.
Right. And he's fucking
sitting there. It's basically,
it's like when the jet pulls into
the airport, you know, and the,
and you're all excited. You're 20 minutes
fucking early. But then the guy gets on,
catch me Qa,
she could see what you arrived
about 11 minutes early yet.
Fortunately our gate is still occupied,
so wow.
Well he doesn't make a difference if
we get here early or not, we're still,
then I'll pull up to the, uh,
the jet way at the same time. So
wow.
Just sit back. We'll actually
as well make sure that got away.
Let you go enjoy the a tonic
right. Same fucking thing. Okay.
So he's fucking guy. Sorry.
I then went on way too long.
I was just trying to remember the
names of the airport shit. Right.
So here's the other guys for
already sitting there. All right.
That Boutros Boutros barley guys
already fucking sitting there.
So he's pulling into the pits.
He knows he can't go there,
so he starts slowing the fuck down, you
know, causing the other fucking guy.
Ricardo hit his spots open.
It's like, dude, get the fuck
out of the way. You know,
we said it's the way the official side,
but I,
I actually agree with the officials
because Lewis Hamilton is, uh, is, is I,
you know, I haven't watched
too much, but I think he's,
he's like that level competitive or he
will pull a little country moves like
that. And I think that that's why he
got paralyzed. You know, cause you know,
it's like, it's like when Marshawn
got busted with the fucking, you know,
the stick to the boss, you know what
I mean? You're going to get suspended.
Cause even when we know we know
the other shit you've done.
So I think Lewis Hamilton gets the
same fucking treatment. Um, anyways,
congratulations to Sebastian fettle and
the Ferrari team. This has been great.
Three races, Ferrari wins. One Mercedes.
When's the other? Now for Ryan,
once the third one I like,
it's gimme a nice back and forth.
Sebastian Vettel leads fucking Lewis
Hamilton by seven championship points,
68 to 61. I'm telling you guys,
get into it. It's like 57 laps.
It's a great fucking time. Go see what
the Illuminati does with their money.
It's a phenomenal God damn sport.
It's already way better than last year
where it was just fucking the Mercedes.
It was a race to the first turn and then
that was it. It was over, but very, uh,
very happy with it this
year. Um, so anyways, um,
what else did I do this weekend? I've been
working out like a fucking maniac. Um,
I actually got on the scale,
so at one 74.
Okay.
You know, I got some acting
work this week. I like to be
about a buck 72, you know,
that's the way I kind
of need to be around.
So I don't look like a big
headed fucking jackass, you know?
Shout out to all you actresses out there
who think only women deal with that.
It's so hard.
It's so Womack's shut up,
shut up. You're in a movie,
shut up. It's like, you know,
how was I going to, I can't be
too loud. My daughter sleeping,
but my wife was watching that,
keeping up with the Kardashians and
they were having a tough moment in their
family, you know, and they
were all sitting there as
you know, you know, it just,
it just seems like it's one thing after
another and I know a lot of families
deal with that, but just, it's been
really fucking, it's been really hard.
And as they're saying this,
they're sitting in a private jet.
Okay.
Being filmed for a television
show on their way to New York City
and they're all sitting there with these
said pound puppy looks on their faces.
I don't give a fuck if I
was going to my own funeral.
If I was on a private jet
to fucking New York City,
I would be getting shit faced. The
pilots would love me, you know,
I wouldn't have a disrupt what they're
doing up there. I would be like,
I'm fucking temperate. You guys. Right.
Okay.
Sitting there all sad.
It's just hard because you know,
with everything that happened last year
to then come into this year and have
more hard things to be happening,
it's just really hard.
Okay.
I would love to take that clip,
you know,
and show it to people who
actually really have problems.
Dual reaction video,
you know,
whoever's sewed together, they're
fucking clothes and I'm guilty of it too.
Everything. I fucking where's made
in a sweatshop. I actually tried,
one time there was a,
there was a website called no sweat.
I don't know if it still exists
and they made all these clothes.
None of it was sweatshop labor.
And I looked at all the clothes and none
of it was cool clothes. And I was like,
wow, I want to do the right
thing, but I can't wear that shit.
All my friends are
going to make fun of me.
Okay.
So I put my own insecurity.
I had a fucking people.
Okay.
Working for sweatshop Labor prices,
I dunno.
I just know it's just
really hard sometimes.
Even if you are in a private jet
on your wage in New York City.
Yeah.
Drinking Champagne.
They weren't even drinking champagne.
They were just sitting
there and looking sad.
They're big fucking brown
cardio machine eyes.
You know what they look like?
One of those fucking creepy paintings,
you know they make a kids with,
remember that that artists that just had
those giant fucking eyes that was like
his thing. They had giant,
these giant fucking creepy eyes.
I gotta look that shit up there. This guy,
this guy actually made a ton of money.
They were considered cute in like the
70s and I always fucking hated them.
I always hated him.
Oh by the way,
if you're wondering how the point
system works in f one you get 25 points.
If you come in first and you get
points all the way down to 10th place,
it goes 25 like (512) 108-6421 I
believe that's how it goes off and then
everybody else can go fuck themselves.
By the way.
How funny was it and that guy drive them
for the Honda's just bitching over the
radio, but what a piece of shit his car
was. He sounded like me in high school,
cause if he's driving a
fucking formula one race car,
he said this is the most under powered
race car I've ever driven in my life.
They're all sitting there like die,
do not on the radio.
And then they cut into his car and
it says Honda on the side of it. Um,
anyways, uh, yeah,
it was a really fascinating race because
there was somewhere in the Middle East
and there was, they were worried
about sand blowing onto the track,
which could chew up the tires and
obviously fucked with the traction. Um,
I don't know. The more I get
into it, the more I like it.
What the fuck was I looking at?
Okay.
Creepy big I kids.
Paintings Seventies.
This is always search for shit.
I better get it. I barely get it.
Come on.
Okay.
The big eyed children, the extraordinary
story of an epic art fraud.
No,
that's not them.
Why does every art gallery have a older
white woman with the really short hair,
like a boy's haircut, but
it's like stylized, you know,
like she sings in oasis
or some shit vintage. Oh,
there it is. Is this it?
Nah, that's not them.
I guess everybody does the big eyed thing.
What does the big eyes,
what the fuck was that thing called?
It wasn't called like love is.
That's not a wow.
A lot of people with the big eyed kids.
A big guide kids in he
fucking big eyed kid.
Love is dot.dot.
Big Eyes.
Let's see if that works.
All right. I give up.
I'm fucking give up down a
show me a picture of spongebob.
Squarepants freaking out on some drugs.
Do you guys know the ones I was
talking about? They had little bodies.
They had giant heads made
these big fucking eyes,
these little pink fucking arms and shit.
They just were,
they were creepy as shit and everybody
thought they were so god damn cute.
I was a dumb kid though.
Do you know what?
Every time I walked into a Photoshop
back then and they'd have picture frames
and then they already have like a picture
in it like I thought that you'll buy
in that picture. My mother one time was
looking at picture frames. I was like,
why would you want that one? I mean,
whose kids are those? She just laughed.
She laughed and she goes,
no,
you take it out and then you put your
picture in there. I was like, oh,
now that I have a kid, I can't imagine
like that's gotta be a terrifying moment.
Like, oh my God, is my kid going to
be homeless? I'll fucking, you know,
come home. You look at you like, like dead
dead. Dumbness was not in me. You know,
you come home and you look at your
spouse, that's you. You did that.
And she was strand a fucking
DNA messing up my 50%.
Thank you very much.
All right,
let me read a little bit of
advertising here for the week. Um,
that's going to drive me nuts. It's
big. I'd fucking kids. All Right,
wink.
When you have a great glass of wine,
it enhances the moment. Yeah.
It's called getting shit faced.
Whether you're reflecting on the
day or with someone you love,
wink understands this.
It's why woo.
They started their company to give you
access to exceptional wines from around
the world.
So you have more of those moments.
I just picture them smashed, cutting to
people, shit face yelling at their kids.
I said,
God,
I just go to try WINC W I n c.com,
spelled t r y w,
I N c.com.
Whiskey India,
November charlie.com.
Take a brief palate profile quiz and wink.
We'll recommend distinct and interesting
wines actually customized to your
pallet to be shipped directly to your door
every month. Why do people drink wine?
Think they're so fucking smart,
customized for your palate.
You getting shit faced. You're
drinking like a pirate. Um,
none of your time is wasted fitting in,
fitting in a run to the store or on your
way home from work or on your way to
invent or a gathering.
No more time spent guessing what
you might like because wink basis,
the wines they send you
on your taste preferences,
Winkle even introduce you to new rare
and custom wines that are not available
anywhere else and tell you the story
behind each one is it's doing it in this
one. It's not approved by the FDA and
somebody made it in the sink. All right,
but it Gabe, we'll get you fucking shit
page. Join for free to skip any month.
Cancel anytime and they have a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee so you
never pay for a bottle you don't like.
And right now Winc is offering
listeners $20 off your first order.
When you go to try winc.com/burr
they'll even cover the cost of shipping.
That's try Winc spelled try w inc com
slash birds get $20 off your first order
now plus complimentary shipping.
Try that's try winc.com/ [inaudible]
now you realize the loophole in there is
that if you're not 100% satisfied,
you never have to pay for
a bottle you don't like.
So what you do is you order
like 10 bottles. Okay? You
take a glass of each one.
It'd be like, yeah, I didn't like
that. Then like that one either.
Get to the 10th one. Yeah. All these
bottles. Sack gimme Tim Moore. All right.
I am not 100% satisfied.
All right. Me undies.
Oh,
too told me undies me on these drink and
your fucking wine to do to to me undies
undies. It's nice and soft on
your behind. When you drink wine,
you're such a cunt. You take
your smart, no you're not.
I couldn't think of anything that
fucking rhymes cause I'm a fucking moron.
Year with velvet ball stuff.
Um, velvet ball stuff, stuff,
velvet stuff up against my balls.
Me undies.
Everybody elevate your underwear game
to the next level with me undies.
You've perfected your wardrobe.
But what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been
settling for store, bought underwear,
five packs.
I have something that will change
your life for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put on the last
thing you take off? Huh? That's right.
It's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of
clothing the best it can be with me.
Andy's sometimes it's your tee
shirt though, right? You know,
you just fucking grabbed you sweatpants
and your NDC just take them off and
you're standing there with tee shirt,
you know, and you fucking socks.
So you get the shower going. Your wife
walks in, she starts laughing at you,
you know you never did that.
Follow up. What is me undies?
Ah,
she is seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your
fucking door and want to meet that guy.
What do you do? I, I, I bring
a deliver underwear to men.
You know, stories don't get along with
people. It takes a special personality.
I'll shut up bill. Me undies are
designed in La or was that Los Angeles?
Louisiana. We don't know. And made from
sustainably source of micro modal, modal,
a fabric three times softer than cotton.
Biondi softer than soft luxury.
Andy's coming in ever changing selection
of classic colors, bold shades,
bold shades,
right around their chef to your Dick and
adventurous patterns so you can tailor
your undies to your own personal style.
You want a giraffe next to your nuts.
How about a sunflower? Guess
what? This is what they do.
You can save time and money each month
with a monthly subscription and if you're
not ready for a subscription,
that's okay. You can still save.
That's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar
and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
A throw out those shits staying
those skid macked undies.
Once again,
that's me,
undies.com/me undies.com/burr how
many more of these fucking things?
I got to read two more.
You want me to read these two and now
you want to hear this story about me
trying to make fucking dumplings?
Let's talk about that.
A where any any fuck Anais it's out there.
Any Asians listen to this podcast and
anybody from the fire east migrated over
here.
Maybe a generation or maybe your family's
like old school and they kept the
tradition going so you know how to make
fucking dumplings. I, I love dumplings.
All right. I'm like Oprah
right now. I love dogs.
I fucking love dumplings.
And I told you the story of when I was
in Singapore and I was on my way to Hong
Kong and I was in the fucking airport
lounge and that con ate all the fucking
dumplings. I swear to God,
I don't know how it was.
Belly wasn't hanging over his pants.
He says little skinny motherfucker.
It was like as a competitive eater,
they kept bringing them out in like in
like groups of like 14 in this fucking
guy would eat like 11 of them.
It's like he was flying around the world
and there was going to be no food in
the God damn plane. So the best dumplings
I ever fucking head. I was in Hong Kong,
I went to some dim sum shit.
I don't know what the hell it was,
but it is a fucking art form over there.
But I'll tell you here in America,
they still do a great job,
but the dumplings, the pots,
I love him. All right. I told you
guys a while ago, I was, you know,
I wanted to get outside my palate and I
never cooked with any of the Asian Shit
even though I love it,
right?
So I decided that I'm going to try and
make these fucking dumplings right.
So of course I don't have any of the
ingredients I need other than the flower.
Hot Water, sugar, salt, what
are the fuck else did I have?
And of course they had some of
that with a soy sauce. I had that,
but everything else I didn't have,
I didn't have anything else.
So I go to the white grocery store,
right?
I go to their little Asian section
that's right next to the Mexican section
that's a little bit bigger.
And then everything else is just for
northern Europeans. I mean that's,
that's a white grocery store. That's what
it's like. Okay. So I say to the guy,
you got to eat his fucking chili sauce.
Do you have any of the dark soy sauce?
And you know,
I actually asked an agent dude that worked
at the fish counter and he was like,
Nah man, they don't have that
shit here. And I was like,
do you know where I can get it? And he was
like, no, I mean, I dunno where you live.
And I was like, all right,
sorry. So I ended up going to,
uh, uh, whatever it was a Korea town, Thai
town, I don't know what the fuck it was.
I went and I went to into this grocery
store and I come walk in whole new
fucking world, all these fucking noodles,
all of this shit I'm looking at going,
that's the stuff when I ordered,
there it is right there. Right.
So I'm looking for my style.
I needed like corn flour
and they didn't have any.
So when I went to the Thai grocery store,
I was looking for it and there was this
Asian lady there with their mother and
she sees me, the fucking white dude
no round. I here looking at the shit,
trying to figure stuff out. And
she starts laughing. She goes,
what are you trying to make?
And then I laughed.
I sent him and try to make dumplings.
So he goes, all right, what do you need?
I said, I'm trying to find corn flour.
And she goes, Oh, you know, it's just,
you know, since she talks to her mother,
we had [inaudible] down there fucking,
you know, the real deal, shit, you know,
bilingual shit going down and they're
trying to help me find the corn.
They couldn't.
So I they found this other shit and
that was close to it and we're like, ah,
I don't know if you can use
that. So I was like, I fuck it.
Maybe I got to go to Chinatown.
I have no fucking idea.
So I thank him and they say,
good luck and I leave.
Then I'm standing up at the
register and was hilarious.
That same woman came up to me
and this is what she says to me.
This is like a minute later, she
goes, uh, excuse me. She goes, well,
you're the guy who was just talking to
and immediately I'm like, oh my God,
we all look alike.
Okay.
So I laugh and I go, yeah.
She goes, I just googled it.
You can use this as a substitute. She
took the time out to Google it. It's like,
you know what, you, you're awesome. She
said, no worries. I said, all right,
see you later. So now I got a new
grocery store to go to. So I come home.
So I go to the meat store,
I get my fucking pork and all that
shit and get my ginger, right.
All this shit that I'm
going to put in there.
So I go to make this make the filling
was fucking easy. My Bok Choy,
fucking cutting up the green onions,
all of that. It's smelling right.
It's looking right,
everything's going good.
Then I go to do the fucking dough and
it, God damn it, that was a motherfucker.
Yeah.
Not Mixing it up. Mixing
it up was easy, but like,
just trying to make them
into a round circle was, uh,
that was not easy. Forget about
folding them up and uh, so whatever.
I put a little oil in the pan.
It took me forever.
It took me like two hours
to do this whole thing.
And I was talking to somebody else
who married into an Asian family.
It was just like, oh man. He
goes, when they do it, they
think fucking how quickly,
you know,
they can fucking get the dumpling together
and fold it up and make it look right.
It's like, it's like a fucking,
it's like magic, you know?
And I'm sitting there all clumsy trying
to get the thing together and it took me
like two hours to get the whole thing
together. And for whatever reason,
this fucking recipe I had like
how many did I have?
I had like fucking like 40 of them.
Okay.
Almost like I almost quit like
15 times just going like, yeah,
how many times can I have
ordered dumplings from the
people that invented them,
that know what the fuck they're
doing. But I plowed ahead. Right.
So we got the oil on the Pan
and I just follow the thing,
you know when they get nice and Golden
Brown, then you pour your water in,
you put the lid on him, you
steam them when the water's
gone, they're done. And uh,
I got to tell you they were,
they were ugly on a scale of one to 10,
they were a strong six. Did Not
look good. Too many different sizes.
Even though the ladies on the,
on the video show me how to do what?
I still fucked that up. And um,
and then, you know, I'm the worst.
I have to stop fucking doing this. Cause
I always go to Nia like, was it good?
How does it taste? Is it good? And
the second she knows I want approval.
Okay.
She turns into fucking Simon Cowl.
She was just saying, Oh, you know,
they're uh, you know, and it's
like, I even said, well listen,
I know these aren't great
for first attempt it. That's
pretty good, right? I look,
you know, insecure fucking
guy that I am. I need to look,
just give me a little fucking feedback
comedian. That's why I like stand up.
How'd you guys like it? Ha ha ha. We it
dead silence around it. Get it. All right.
I want this one now. Do you like
math? Do you like me again? You know,
that's how I live my life. I lived moment
to fucking moment. Not in a zen way,
just in a completely insecure way.
Right?
So she's not giving it up and I go,
so we know what's, what's, what's up.
She goes to something,
uh, well, I don't know.
The doe is just not a,
you know,
she's clearly just opening them up and
just eating the middle out of them.
I go to, to like sticky, she goes, no,
that's not the word.
Um,
and immediately I'm just like, Oh God,
I just want to fucking just, yeah.
Um,
gummy.
Yeah.
Is that the worker? Yes. Sticky gummy.
You want it to the source. How
are you? Say The fucking word.
So this is what happened is,
you know,
I learned from the chef that you
gotta be, you know, tasting your food.
I feel ever I used to cook
and I wouldn't be tasting,
so I was tasting them the whole fucking
way. And the chef told me, you know,
by the time it's done,
you're not going to want any
because you've tasted so much of it.
So I'd already had so many fucking
dumplings the time I got it.
Like I was almost a little
sick and I fucking hate him.
And I knew that they weren't right.
But I definitely had a good time.
I think I would quarter that
recipe solely, only make
like fucking eight of them.
Then I could have fun and I could
actually like take my time rather than do.
It was like,
I swear to God,
it was so perfect that I did it during
tax time because that's what it felt like.
You know,
when you get all your receipts all
laid out and all these little balls of
fucking flower.
But um,
okay.
Ah, dude, this morning,
like I didn't even clean up.
I went downstairs and I was just like
a dumplings and I had a fucking scotch.
I was doing so well on my diet
and next day of fucking woke up,
looked like a starving child with
it, like a distended belly, you know,
if that should starving child
was an alcoholic. And um,
so I fucking,
I came upstairs and just the smell of
that fucking soy sauce and all that should
have to all those dumplings I
fucking hate. And I swear to God,
I actually have a new found
respect for that son of a bitch.
They all adopt those dumplings in,
uh,
in Singapore. I don't know what the
fuck that guy's stomach is made out of,
but food, you can't eat all
of that dough. So, um, Dan,
of course eating like that
kind of threw me off my diet.
Went to this fucking great cookout
today and I, I, you know, I ate well,
but not well, if you know what I mean.
So who knows. Whatever I'm doing. Well,
I'm doing one with the Diet. I'm still,
I'm still going in the right direction.
Okay. I've shaved off about eight pounds
off of the fucking Christmas Ham here.
Oh, bill is going to be able to fit in
as suits in about another five pounds.
Get down like one 71 71. That's it.
Then we're trying that suit again.
You know why?
Cause I'm not a quitter.
I hung in there with the dumplings some,
but I'm not going to fucking
go down to the, I'm not,
I'm not going to be that guy.
I told you guys then I'm not going to
be the guy that goes down to the dry
cleaners and it has this fucking suits.
Let out sitting here with you.
Fucking shoulders slumped.
All right? And if you're,
if you're in that right now,
if you're doing that right now,
you got to keep one fucking suit.
Okay.
That you don't do that too.
And I would make it your favors fucking
suit the one you look the best and
that's it.
You don't have your fat suits.
He literally wearing a fat suit like
fucking Eddie Murphy in the clumps,
except when they say cut, you know, in
the end of the day they can't remove it.
What, what are you doing? Get on a fucking
treadmill. All right. Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody buying a razor.
It's a lot like buying a car except
it's yet wait, wait. Cheaper. Uh,
to get smooth luxury,
luxury quality,
you have to pay a huge price and that
means you're paying mostly for splashy
marketing and features. You don't actually
need switched to dollar shave club.
It's this choice.
The luxury quality at an economy price,
dollar shave club's razors
are amazing quality.
They've got the shaved technology you
need and none of that overpriced gimmicky
shit.
You don't have you seen the ad for the
raises monopolies newest razor thing.
It's like a 24 blades swivel,
pivot robot razor with the laser pointer
every year they make a tiny change of
the rate,
tiny change to the razor and then try
to convince you it's totally new and you
need to spend even more forward.
And then the new blades don't fit your
old fucking handle all that Steve Jobs
Shit. Join Dollar Shave Club
and be done with all of that.
There's never been a better time to give
them a shot right now you can get the
first month of their amazing
racist for only a buck,
including free shipping and after
that it's just a few bucks a month.
There's no long term commitments.
Relax, no hidden fees.
You can cancel whenever you want.
Get your first month for just
aBuck@dollarshaveclub.com
slash bird that's dollar
shave club.com/bar one more read.
Oh and it's nice and quick.
stamps.com these people get it man.
Got a nice quick copy.
I use stamps.com to send out any of my
posters anytime or myself after my shows
if I can figure it out. So can you
stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business
or just sit there and stare at the wall,
drinking your favorite bourbon.
I can mail any letter,
any package using my computer and my
printer and the mailman comes by and picks
it up.
Avoid the hassle man,
and go into the post office and mail
everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages,
domestic or international stamps.com
we'll even help you decide the best class
of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive
postage meter right now.
Here we go. The big finale.
You can enjoy the stamps service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital
scale without a longterm commitment.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstampsdotcomandtobarstamps.com
never go to the post office again
unless you're one of those Weirdos that
collect stamps. Okay? All
right. Let's get to some of the,
uh, some of the fucking questions
here for the week, shall we?
Shall we
the lovely knee.
Everybody is my food here. Oh yeah,
that's been here. It's been here.
What did I order again?
A salad with chicken.
Cause you're on a diet. Yes. Everybody
knows I was talking to you about your,
your, your cold calculated
review of my dumplings.
What are you talking about? You know how
you do. Hey Sweetie, what's up buddy?
You just woke up. Movie that smile. Nod.
Oh she's, you know what I'm, I know I'm
bias, but we got, we got one cute ass kid.
Uh Yeah, we're done. Yeah,
you're done. Ew. Ew. Ew. Ew.
Ew.
Made dumplings.
See this is what I'm talking about.
It's so cold.
Yes. You A ew. Ew. Ew. You
May, dumplings tried. I mean,
you know you made it. I don't
mean you tried. You did make it.
No you can't. This is, this is, you
can't, you can't give it up ever.
I become hard.
This is who you give it up.
Okay.
You know, I, I'm,
I feel like I'm very honest with you
is what it is because I respect you so,
Ooh,
you're going to turn this around.
That was a nice little flippy do that
you did there because I respect you.
I'm going to be honest with you. If I
didn't respect you, I would just be like,
oh yeah, everything you
do is amazing. Well wait,
that didn't come out right either.
What I'm trying to say is,
I think they put forth a great,
I'm just going to, you keep talking your
way down this fucking well, I'm done.
I'm done. I'm done. Yeah.
Okay. Well, you know what?
I realize I respect you too.
What does that mean?
It means I'm going to start
being as honest as you are.
That's what I'm going to do. What is it
exactly that you're upset with me about?
Cause you can't just be like, you know,
they're, they're all right then a great,
that would be perfect, but
you have to be like, um,
there's something with the dough and I
was just like, is it sticky? You're like,
wow, Ooh, that's not the word. Oh,
she's just let me just put two behind my
ear and I'll move onto the next fucking
meal.
Then you had to finally just
be like on gummy sat the word.
That's what,
and then he said what gummy means.
You can live like blow bubbles with it.
And I just couldn't even say anything
because if I said anything I would start
laughing because obviously I don't
mean that you can blow bubbles with it.
I know you just, you're a, you're
a tough, you're a tough one.
You're a tough one. It's, it's
tough to get a compliment out of,
you feel like dumplings
are also easy to make.
You know what I mean? It was your
first try. They looked amazing.
The feeling was good.
Just the dough part was,
it's definitely off. I think I like
overcooked it, I think, I'm not sure,
but I'm not, I'm just saying you
have like, you have this dislike,
you just take out the sickle when it's,
when it's coming and you turn it like go
down the Olympic judge to be like eager
to be like, yet. I mean they're
not the best, but you know,
you'll get them on the next one.
Give me a little pat on the fucking head.
You're just like, nope,
these are not good.
Have a nice evening.
I will see you in the morning.
All right. I'll take this
opportunity. You won't.
I've been talking to you about
this for fucking 14 years.
Hey Buddy.
Oh,
can I take a bite out of this hour?
Huh?
Why can't you say this age forever?
These be this big,
big ball of cute.
We carry around.
She's got a mischievous look on her face.
You're going to be Tuffy tonight?
Like last night. Last night. Yeah.
I'll tell you it was a rough one.
I let,
let me finish this up here so I can go
eat my cold fish or chicken or whatever.
I ordered chicken.
All right.
I'm not,
you're way off the microfiber.
Even annoying the shit out of people for
the last five minutes. Okay. All right.
Hey Nia,
that that dress is,
I mean it's address your,
you're wearing it
and I still, I can't even do it to you.
You look great asshole. Get out of here.
Alright, wagon, please read.
Please read. Hey there,
Billy baby white as the
first kid. One. All right.
I heard you the email you read a couple
of weeks ago about the older guy who was
wondering if it was worth it to lay off
the booze and reconnect with his family.
I can tell you I wasn't
as bad as that guy,
but it made me realize I
could be a better person.
I quit boozing two days
after I heard his story.
I called my brother and
I started a dialogue.
I should've started eight years ago.
I used to listen to you talk about
boobs and think it was an excuse to keep
boozing, not placing the blame on
you. I'm a moron. Well, yeah, I mean,
I don't know you so I wouldn't think
that you were trying to blame me.
I wouldn't accept the blame either.
Uh,
but then I realized you don't drink all
day every day and that you have a full
career in a kid and a wife.
I have a plumbing and
heating job and a terrier.
I still smoke weed because
it helps with my arthritis,
which is actually very severe and
prevents me from doing things.
It just picturing you're jerking off.
God Damn it. I can't, I can't sustain.
It prevents me from doing things like
running and lifting comfortably. Uh,
the call to my brother initiated.
Um,
well I bet taking all that booze out
of your system would probably help out.
I don't think booze and is good for
your joints. Is it all that sugar?
I don't, I don't, I, I always just repeat
shit that I half listened to. I'm sorry.
The call my brother initiated
his inviting me to Easter. Nice.
The first holiday I was spelling my
family and almost nine years. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. All right, well,
I don't know what you thanking me for.
You did it. I don't know that
I said anything. By the way.
My wife was watching Dr Phil.
Okay.
And they had this fucking
guy on there. I, I,
it was one of the most fucked
up things I've ever seen on TV.
This guy was basically
going on the Internet.
He was into conspiracy theory and he lost
his job and he went and got into this
meditating thing and he said he
had reached this spiritual plane.
Okay.
Um,
of constant meditation.
And nobody and he couldn't
explain it to anybody around him,
like his wife and doctor.
Phil's trying to talk to the guy and
he goes and he just kept going like,
so what are you trying,
you're, you're meditating,
you're on the Internet,
you're meditating.
And then the guy just kept taking this
arrogant like line with him going.
Yeah, see once again, I
mean you'd have to read up.
I mean I can't just explain this to you.
I can send you links on to try to get to
my level basically of higher thinking.
And then doctor Phil's like Dow,
talk down to me.
K, first of all, you don't know me.
I'm one of the most open minded people
you're ever going to me. First of all,
who the fuck says that about themselves?
Oh,
I'm one of the greatest people I've
ever met. Right? So long story short,
they bring in Deepak Chopra.
All right,
another whore of spirituality.
You know,
he's a horror of psychology and this
fucking jerk off comes in with these
fucking bright red sneakers on and sits
down next to this guy and the guy's
freaking out cause he feels like
he's on the same plane as this guy.
And then he proceeds to basically say
that this guy is a abandoning his family.
He picked his words carefully.
I will say that about a old fucking
Depok d to The motherfucking Chopra.
He basically picked his words carefully,
but in the end he said to Dr Phil
that he feels this guy is bipolar.
Okay,
this fucking poor bastard found out that
he was bipolar on national television.
Like, Oh and the guy fucking scissor.
Excellent. He's helping people.
Basically,
you're bipolar.
You're not reaching a higher spiritual
plane as much as you are experiencing a
episode.
MMM.
Yeah.
Just doing that judge Judy Shit,
where's he's talking all tough to
two minutes into it, I was like,
this guy needs some serious psychological
help, but I, I don't, I don't know shit.
Okay.
Fucking Depok coming out
with making this face.
I'm trying to think who the fuck he looks
like. I don't know what he looks like.
Liberace.
Okay.
Whatever, whatever national, what
is he? Is He Indian ease? Like if,
if India had a Liberace, this, this,
would they ever do the fucking Michael
Douglas, Matt Damon version of Liberace?
If they do it in some Bollywood thing
that he got to, you got to cast that guy.
MMM.
Any, I love that he was just available
to, does he live out in Hollywood?
All right.
Anyways, I have no fucking idea.
I don't know anymore. You know,
one of my favorite things too is my wife
is on Instagram and Instagram's a pain
in the ass because if you're not on it,
you can't look at the photos and shit.
And I just can't join
another social media site.
But one of my favorite fucking things
of those people who take up pictures of
themselves in their amazing bodies after
they work out and rather than theirs in
saying,
don't I look fucking amazing,
they actually act like they're
trying to motivate you. You know,
like reach Hashtag reached your goal.
MMM.
The hashtag putting that work in.
Um,
I just,
I think I've just,
I've just become an old man now and
I don't understand younger people.
I just don't understand like it did the
level of dose chills that you would take
a picture of yourself while
you're working out, you know,
under the guise that you're trying
to motivate people. You know, like,
this isn't about me guys. This is
in my eight pack. This is about you.
I'm trying to,
I try to inspire people with my beauty.
MMM.
That's why I don't believe in Christ.
Okay.
When I just see moments like that, it's
just like, what is God waiting for?
When are you going to send this dude
back? Like, how bad does it have to get,
you know, in a way, I almost blame God at
this point. It's like you're enabling us.
How long you going to keep letting us
have the intelligence to advent these
devices to further disappear
up our own ass holes?
As I sit on a podcast talking
to myself for a fucking hour.
Ah, Jesus. I swear to God. Every
time. I think I'll make it a point.
I just realized what a fucking
hypocrite I am. All right.
Little girl statue in Syria.
Okay.
This sounds like clickbait.
You know when you see little
girl finds a statue in Syria,
what she does next will shock you.
You know,
you click on it and there's
one photo in 87 ads.
Fuck all of those sites.
Um,
all right bill for days people flooded
Facebook and praise of the little girl
statue they placed in front of
the Wall Street bull. Everybody,
mostly women and social justice
warriors went on about resisting.
Okay.
And how powerful the statue was.
I choose to fight.
Um, it turns out the little girl statue
was put up by a media slash marketing
company that has zero interest in
doing anything but creating a buzz for
themselves. Um, that's not,
that's not all the bullets.
Self was a piece of art erected
by an independent artist.
It was panned by Wall Street
and they wanted it removed.
The people kept it there.
Everyone is a sucker. Uh,
whenever that means.K O n y 2012 I cited
a source below unless the rest of the
twats
okay
on Facebook. Thank you. Skipped some words
here. Sorry for the stomach growling.
Um,
also that white hat document mentoree
that went everywhere about the group of
volunteers that came to the aid of Syrian
chemical weapons victims was part of a
huge agenda to make America
mad at the Syrian regime.
International reporters are questioning
the source of those weapons.
Some think it was even, it wasn't even
the Syrian government. We're all fucked.
Love you love Nia. Congrats
on the little lady. Um,
yeah, I believe all that type of
shit. I believe that type of shit. Um,
I don't know if any of that type of stuff,
but I definitely believe that they show
images to make us fucking upset about
stuff. You know, um,
seems very easy to defeat terrorism.
To me,
all you do is just embrace the electric
cars. Just make everything electric.
We stopped buying oil from those guys.
They don't have any money.
They go bankrupt and next thing you know,
they can't afford anything but rocks.
We're not over there.
They gradually forget about us.
They go back to arguing with one
another and we just slowly back away.
Why don't we just do that? You know
why? Because there's no money in that.
That's what I think, but what
do I know? All right. Terrified.
Okay.
Have a threesome. Can I, can I click on
this link up here? What does this link?
This person sent me? I don't know why.
Oh, I know why because I don't have it.
I got to click on it
when it's in the email.
What's in the eat when it's an email?
Now how do I find what the fucking email
is? Live reads. Blow my, go to that.
Click on inbox.
Retrace all my steps.
Go to the contents,
scroll down,
click on the link.
Wait for it to open.
It is now trying to load. All right,
I'll get back to that in a minute.
In the meantime, terrified of
a threesome. Hey parentheses,
insert cheap redhead insult here. Huge
Fan love you. Stand up andF is for family.
Thank you.
I'm 20 I'm a 21 year old college student
who has a girlfriend that is bisexual
and beautiful as well.
God bless you.
Woo.
God bless you sir.
God bless you.
There's no way you don't believe
in God, man. God bless you.
We've talked about asking girls to join
us in bed and are finally getting ready
to have it happen.
The girl that's joining us is a girl that
the both of us have gotten with in the
past at different times.
Ah, this is perfect.
The only problem is that I get freaked
the fuck out when I think about this
happening. Both of the women
involved are hot and experience,
which is what scares me.
I'm not that astounding looking of a guy,
not that well in doubt.
As far as my dick goes and not
experienced at all. Come here.
You're going to talk yourself out of
this dude and not experienced at all
compared to these girls. I do. I get
past my fears and relaxed enough to make,
to be into what's happening and make
sure I make it worthwhile for both these
ladies. Thanks. And Go
fuck yourself. Uh, two,
do not fuck this up.
Okay.
The only way you can fuck
this up is to not show up.
To show up and let nature take over.
Okay? It's all right to be freaked out.
You're 21 years old.
You've got to fucking smoking hot chicks,
one of fucking banging at the same
time. That's a lot. This rockstar shit.
I Dunno what you do for a living, but I'm
guessing you're not a fucking rockstar.
So yeah, this is a, this is,
this is fucking great. This
is a great God damn thing.
Um, you know, and if you
want to, I'll just tell you
girlfriend, just be like, yeah,
I'm excited and I'm a, I'm got to
be going to seem a little nervous.
You guys are both so, but just keep
paying it back cause it's so beautiful.
Now things should we tell women you're
lax, just follow my lead. Just do that.
Just be open and honest about it.
But don't take it to the
fucking point that you like.
Don't say all that other shit.
You know, just look the guy,
I could have had a bigger dick
than, she's going to think, well,
what the fuck am I doing this with
you for? Don't go that far. All right,
here's the thing dude.
You definitely good looking enough.
You definitely got a big enough dick.
Oh, none of this shit would be happening,
right? Okay. You got
called up to the shell.
Okay. Get up to the plate and
swing out of your fucking cleats.
I would let them start. Let them start
and then you just kind of fucking,
you know, work your way in. That's all.
Just start making out with both of them.
That's it. Get some fucking, I dunno,
I don't just, just
please, please do please.
For the Sunday 48 year old you who
probably be doing a podcast by himself.
Okay? Please don't fuck this up. Okay?
Don't do not talk yourself out of this.
You getting in your fucking head.
All right?
You've already gotten with both of them.
She obviously likes you,
Dick Sheiks coming back for
more you girlfriends still
there. This is just like,
this is something else,
dude,
and this is a great experience for you
to push past all that fucking low self
esteem. All right, so man, have fucked up.
Have a great time. Follow up email please.
All right. My girl loves me too much. No,
but I can't love myself at all. All
right. Hey, Billy moose knuckle.
I always forget what that is.
I know what a camel toe is.
I don't know what a moose knuckle is.
A,
I'm a 22 is that a Canadian camel toe?
I don't know.
I'm a 22 year old college student and
I've been with my girlfriend for about a
year now.
Things have been great.
Only problem is that she's
got the tendency to tell me,
I love you or you're so important to me,
or I adore you at least 15 times a
day without any lead up. Oh yeah,
that's creepy. She just does
it out of the blue. I guess.
It's nice to hear,
but after a point it makes me wonder
if she has some underlying issue.
I'm the first boyfriend and she's still
shocked even after dating for a year
that someone finds her attractive.
Sorry. Hiccups are coming.
I'm on top of all this.
She gets weird and passive aggressive.
When I suggest I have a night
to myself saying things like,
I guess I'll stay home alone or I'll
just eat leftover soup and watch the food
network. This shit kills me and
I usually cave and come over.
I'm an introvert at heart and need my
time alone to recharge and study or read
my favorite books when we're together.
We mostly watch movies,
talk about school or fuck, which is fine,
but I need to be alone once in awhile.
I have too much empathy
and I'm a pushover,
which doesn't help anything and it
doesn't help anything. I need some advice.
Do you think she has an attachment
problem or is it something else?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
I would just work on your end of it.
Whatever her issue is, it might come
to a head when you just say, listen,
I just need a long time.
Sometimes you know,
and let her pout and do whatever
the fuck she wants to do.
And eventually she'll
accept that about you.
Or she'll tell you why she's too insecure
to not spend the night and you know,
spend a night alone or she'll flip
the fuck out and you'll be like,
wow, I'm not with the right
person, but I can tell you this,
I'm not doing what you want to do in
a relationship is the quickest way to
poison the water.
Okay.
And I don't mean just going
out and fucking around and
doing all shit like that,
but I mean like, you know, if
you don't like going to Brunch,
you have to tell him you don't
like going to brunch now.
You still have to go to some brunches,
but you're not going to be going
to them all the time. All right?
To not tell her that you're an introvert
at heart and you need your time alone
to recharge and study and all that
type of shit. Read your favorite books,
you know,
she has to respect that about you and
you got to respect that about you. Okay.
Stop giving into what the
fuck she wants. Um, what you,
you were having a night alone every
once in a while is not a crazy request.
Okay. And, um, I would do that
first and see how she reacts.
And you might get to the
bottom of why she has to say,
I love you and I adore you and all of
that shit 50 times a fucking day probably.
Cause you're a, she's probably terrified
that it's not going to end well.
You know, she's, if she's
never had another boyfriend,
I'm guessing she's around your age.
Maybe that gave her some sort of complex,
I don't fucking know.
This is some few guys to work out,
but I got to tell you this right now.
If you need a long time,
you got to tell her that or else you're
gonna end up presenting her and the
whole relationship is going to gradually
start. It's fucking downward spiral. And,
um, and that's it. And it crashes and
Burns right in the fucking cornfield.
Okay. That's it. That's the
podcasts, uh, for this week. Um,
I said everything that I wanted to talk
about, I got Boise, Idaho coming up. Uh,
this we can,
yes.
Next weekend I'll be out there with
Rosebowl tailgate legend and puck off host
all things, comedy network
podcasts, or, uh, Joe part. Nick.
We're going to have a great time
on her up there. Um, that is all.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday.